hello everyone my name is ritu sharma
and i am a research fellow at pine
biotech
today's presentation is based on my
project
which is on the topic surveillance of
sars over two variants of concern from
wastewater samples so the objective of
my
so the objective of my
project is to learn and analyze variants
of concern in sample and perform msa and
phylogenetic analysis using ngs data
employing t bioinfo server
these following are the list of contents
which are involved in the today's
presentation
so
based on the learning which i have done
during the course is introduction to
bioinformatics
bioinformatics is the application of
computer technology and statistics to
the management and analysis of
biological information
in this we gather store and analyze and
integrate biological information many of
the recent groundbreaking discoveries in
biology chemistry environmental science
and other research areas are rooted in
bioinformatics
big data is a collection of data and is
in huge volume which is used for data
driven discoveries data driven
discoveries mainly include six steps
that is identifying question second
review findings
third designing model fourth gathering
data
fifth analyzing data and
sixth is implementation of the result
bioinformatics has been proved to be a
boom in
many industries in many field like
health care industries and agricultural
industries so in healthcare it is
helpful in making precision medicine
drug discovery preventive medicines and
gene therapy
translational bioinformatics is also an
emerging field which brings biological
research into clinical significance in
both patient care and drug discovery
next learning is about the r coding
which is which was learned
for pair by sequence alignment and
multiple sequence alignment so pairwise
sequence alignment means aligning two
sequences and is also the basis of
database similarity searching and
multiple sequence alignment there are
two methods of psa that is global
alignment and local alignment
on the other hand multiple sequence
alignment is the method used to compare
multiple long and short sequences to
find matching portions introduce gaps
and find consensus sequence
here in the two
pictures
which we can see on the slide
tells us about the different r codes for
psa and msa respectively
first we need to load the libraries then
we need to
load the data string and then
we need to give a command for pairwise
alignment or multiple sequence alignment
accordingly and then the last command is
for the print
printing the alignment
genome sequencing there are mainly three
genome sequencing which we which i have
learned
so the first one is targeted ngs
sequencing it is a rapid and cost
effective way to detect known and normal
variants in selected sets of genes or
genomic regions whole genome sequencing
provides a comprehensive picture of
information in the genome by reading
both coding and non-coding sequences in
short it reads the whole genome from
start to the end involving the
non-coding regions and the coding
regions wgs generates more detailed look
at the information of our dna
whole exome sequencing on other hand
targets only the protein coding regions
of the genome providing less coverage
and is it all only gives us the
information about the coding regions of
the genome
variant calling refers to the task of
identifying possible variations in
genome or transcriptome sequence with
respect to chosen reference sequence so
it tells us about the
different variations in the genome
with respect to the reference you know
reference sequence which helps us to
identify the mutation
in the reference genome
according to the reference genome in the
sample so there are two types of variant
variations variant callings that is
germline variant calling and somatic
variant calling so jump line variant
callings are these are the variations
which are present by birth and does not
get transferred from one generation to
another and are usually taken as the
reference sequence of the standard
species
for this species of interest somatic
variant calling on the other hand are
the variations which are developed with
the course of time and does not get
transferred from one generation to
another and they are usually taken as
control somatic sample cell samples
the whole genome
is read
into two methods two methods that is by
period and reads and by single entry so
in pair and reads the fragment is right
from both the ends towards the center of
the fragment in single end the
sequencing fragment is read from one end
to the other towards the another end
here is phylogenetic tree which we can
see it's a dendogram there are many
different uh tree representations in
phylogenetic analysis but here we have
taken the dendogram so phylogenetic tree
tells us about the closely evolutionary
relationship with among the species and
their origin
so here in the diagram a b c d e are
referred to as texon and the branch
which is emerging from a common origin
which is the node
gives two clade that is c and d and a
and b so c and d is in one plate
which tells us that they are very
closely
related to each other we they are very
if they are in close relationship with
each other
mutability in simple terms describe the
observed rate of given position to the
change or muted
differential mutation is an evolutionary
algorithm that processes a population of
individual represented by dimensional
vectors of real numbers
copy number variation is a very is this
type of variation in which a section of
genome is repeated and the number of
repeats in the genome varies between
individual in this human
population
here are the different pipeline graphs
which i have learned during my course
to
to identify
different
things like variant calling mutability
analysis phylogenetic tree analysis and
copy number variation so different
pipelines are used for analyzing the
result for different things
the pipeline i used here for my
result an interpretation with the data
set which i got from ncbi
for surveillance of sarsko v2 variant of
concern from wastewater sample which is
my
project title
i got the sample for
wastewater samples from us and uk which
were taken as control and i have taken
the reference to sequence as the
severe respiratory coronavirus isolate
from wuhan
the pipeline graph which is shown in
this slide was if i
use performed that is for phylogenetic
tree analysis and the result i got is
this tree
so the result interpreted is
the sample er
r5019830 and err5019834
are in same clade in the phylogenetic
tree and have closer evolutionary
relationship with reference you know
since common node for both plates
sample
err5019835 and
err5019840 are in the same plate and
also shear
disclose a distant evolutionary
relationship with outgrowth sample
in the fig in the phylogenetic tree the
sample
err5019836 and er50198
three eight are in different clade and
which does not have closer revolutionary
relationship with the reference genome
or outgrowth sample as they are in
different clades in the last
this research paper is based on my uh
topic that is the surveillance of cyrus
variants of for from wastewater which i
considered for to
read in my
co in my uh med
project so it is on monitoring sarsko v2
population in wastewater by amplicon
sequencing and using the novel program
sam refiner in this research some
refiner program was developed and used
to
find out the variance of concern in
wastewater sample so as a result
as a result two variants of concern were
reported that is alpha and gamma
thanks this was all for
my today's presentation thank you